well ladies and gentlemen Carrie Lake
said she would win she said there was no
way she would lose unless it was stolen
or rigged or fraudulent she insisted
even hours uh into yesterday's final
counting in Arizona that she would
ultimately Prevail and become the next
governor of Arizona
and Carrie lake has lost it is good news
for sensible people and sane people not
only in Arizona not only in the United
States but it is good news for the world
we have a world as Donald Trump famously
said and that world is rejoicing other
than some clowns in Arizona
because Kerry Lake will not be the next
governor of that state instead it will
be Katie Hobbs the Democrat a completely
uncontroversial unremarkable just normal
Democrat who will hopefully run Arizona
in something approximating a logical way
she won't say well we're going to
succeed she won't say end covid
lockdowns and mandates that don't exist
she won't try to ban abortion and on and
on and on it has been a very slow count
in Arizona but it was finally called
yesterday Katie Hobbs prevailing over
Kerry Lake Carrie Lake adding yet
another major endorsement fracchus to
Donald Trump's list
and um Carrie Lake and many others
insisting that it is indeed fraud we
will look at Kerry Lake's reaction in a
moment at the current time it is a
nearly 20 000 vote margin for Katie
Hobbs
um under one point understand but uh it
has been called and it is fortunately
very much over what makes this all the
sweeter and I admit I take pleasure in
this what makes this all the sweeter is
the degree of arrogant confidence that
Kerry Lake exhibited up until quite
literally hours before this was called
The Arrogant confidence of Donald Trump
insisting that Kerry Lake would win but
it started to Flip Flip Flip and get to
the point where well based on the
remaining votes Carrie Lake needs 53
percent now of the remaining votes
Carrie Lake needs 56 percent we knew
days ago that mathematically it really
just wasn't adding up for Kerry Lake and
indeed we have made it now what about
Carrie Lake's Twitter feed well it's
been relatively quiet she has a pinned
message from September and then only one
tweet that seems to be related to the
call
which is Arizona's no BS when they see
it arizonans know BS when they see it
and of course I had to get in there uh
and respond to her and tell her indeed
arizonans SOB the BS of your campaign
and they voted for your opponent
um a a repetitive screeds and tirades
from Kerry Lake shouldn't election
officials be impartial the guys running
the election have made it their mission
to defeat America First Republicans and
then if there was an issue with your
ballot
please submit the information here
attention your vote may not have been
counted you can check the status at
carilake.com cure this is a whole thing
where they want to cure the ballots and
as all of you know
why cure with so much salt when you can
cold smoke and get all the flavor in a
much less salty ballot I prefer cold
smoking rather than curing but that's a
culinary question for later
um Carrie like continuing you know your
vote may not have been counted and on
and on and on uh she is not conceited as
of this point in time I could not care
less whether or not she concedes as many
of you know concession is merely a
formality it is something that you know
reasonable people do even lunatic Doug
mastriano
called Josh Shapiro and said sir I
concede I concede sir you have won this
election
um something Donald Trump never really
did after 2020. and Kerry Lake may not
do it either but a victory for common
sense in Arizona let's continue talking
about this a little bit more I love
cooking at home I cook all the time
having a good set of knives that you
actually like to use is really important
for years I have been a fan of the
advantages that Japanese knives offer
and our sponsor kamikoto makes amazing
Japanese steel kitchen knives using the
traditional techniques that date back to
the Edo period of Japan kamikoto only
uses steel from Japan each blade takes
years to craft and goes through a
rigorous 19-step inspection process with
a lifetime guarantee the knives come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box
makes it a really great gift easy to
store as well on the kamikoto website
you can see a map of the Michelin star
chefs all over the world using kamikoto
knives my kamiko photo knives at home
have been performing great for years you
really just can't beat the feel of a
nice Japanese knife perfectly balanced
in your hand and kamikoto is now running
a big Black Friday sale my audience gets
an extra fifty dollars off go to
kamikodo.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below